let's say I've got some set a of the
vectors a1 a2 all the way to a N and I
know for a fact that it's a basis it's a
basis for the subspace V what I want to
show you in this video is that if this
guy has n elements right here and
elements right here that any set that
spans V has to have at least n elements
so any any spanning spanning set must
have at least n elements and elements or
n members or cardinality of n there's
all just a ways of saying you got n
vectors in this set so let's see if we
could if we could if we have if I'm
saying that every set that spans V must
have at least n elements if this sum
basis set has n elements for V what
let's let's see if we can kind of run
with a set that has less than n elements
and see if we reach any contradictions
so let's say that I have some set B here
and it's equal to the vectors v1 v2 all
the way to be M and M is less than n so
I have some set of vectors here that
have fewer elements than my set a and
let's say that B spans have you come to
me one day and you say look I got I
found you the set of vectors right here
and not only it does it have fewer
elements than a but it spans V it spans
V and I look at you very suspiciously
because I always thought that this green
statement was true so we start out a
little bit of a thought experiment and I
say ok you you claim that your set spans
V so let's do something let me define a
new set let me call this new set B 1
Prime and you'll see why I'm doing this
kind of strange notation what what I
what's essentially going to be is the
set B plus my vector a 1 so it's a 1 and
then I have all of my elements of B so B
1 B 2 all the way to
I am now I think you and I could both
agree that this set is linearly
dependent linearly dependent how do I
know that linear dependence means that
at least one of the elements of the set
can be represented as a linear
combination of the others well we know
that a one I mean it's one of the basis
vectors for V is for this definition of
a basis but all of the basic spec basis
vectors our members are members of V
right you can obviously represent you
can obviously the the the if this if
this set is a basis for V then this
means that this set spans B or that
every member of V can be represented as
a linear combination of these guys or in
other ways every linear combination of
these guys is in V and one of the linear
combinations of these guys is you just
said you know the coefficient on a want
to be zero and everyone else the
coefficient on a one to be one and the
coefficients on everyone else to be zero
so obviously a one is also in the set so
if a one is in V and all of these guys
span V by definition if these guys span
V some linear combination of these guys
can be used to construct any member of V
so you can take some linear combination
of these guys to construct a one so you
could say a one is equal to maybe one
where the DS are the constants D 1 B 1
plus D 2 B 2 all the way to DM BM and at
least one of these have to be nonzero we
know that a is a nonzero vector if it
was a zero vector this couldn't be a
basis because it wouldn't be linearly
independent because you can always
represent a zero vector as a as a as
really just a zero times any other
vector so this won't be a zero vector so
at least one of these are nonzero so
let's just say for the sake of argument
that GJ so the coefficient on BJ is
nonzero so DJ does not equal zero so we
could actually do is we could solve for
that term you know so over here
someplace you have the term DJ BJ and
it's plus a bunch of other stuff we can
solve for this term if we subtract four
from both sides of the equation and then
divide both sides by Nimai
DJ and put this - a1 on the other side
what do we get I know there was a lot of
operations but that's just straight-up
algebra I think you can say that we
could rewrite this right here we can
solve for BJ we could solve for our BJ
term and say that is equal to 1 sorry
that should be equal to minus 1 over its
coefficient times and if we subtract the
a1 from both sides minus a 1 and then
plus all of these guys plus D 1 B 1 plus
all the way you're gonna you're gonna
have a little bit of a gap here I'll
just draw it like that it's very
unconventional notation where this guy
sat all the way to DM BM and I'm doing
all of this just to show you that by
definition you can write a 1 as a linear
combination of these other guys but you
can just rearrange things you can
rearrange it so that you can write you
can write one of the other guys as a
linear combination of the rest of the
other guys and a 1 and you say you know
what and this guy is now redundant I
don't need I don't need this guy any
longer to continue to span V clearly
this set still span V I mean I added
extra in for an extra vector here but I
can remove this guy right here I can
remove him from my set B 1 Prime and
still span V and how do I know that
because I can achieve him by removing
him I don't lose anything because if I
needed this vector to create some other
vector I can construct him with a linear
combination of the rest of the B's plus
my AI or my a1 so let's get rid of him
and let's call that set b1 and actually
just for the sake of notation let me
just change his name let me just say
this is a little unconventional you
won't see it done like this in any
textbook but I think it's a little bit
easier instead of having to keep talking
about these little these guys that are
embedded someplace in in the middle of
the stream I mean these these names B 1
B 2 BM they're arbitrary names so let me
just rename let me swap the labels let
me just say that BJ is equal to V 1 and
that B 1 is equal to BJ I'm just
swapping their names so I'm essentially
just gonna remove I took that guy I
renamed him B 1 Irene a
to be 1bj so that I could swap them so
I'm essentially just going to remove b1
from the vector just to make my notation
easier you could just keep saying I'm
gonna remove this bj from the middle but
it becomes very confusing then so let me
call my new set after removing the BJ
that I've removed that I've renamed is
b1 let me just call that straight-up b1
so my straight-up set B 1 is equal to a
1 a 1 and then remember I removed the BJ
and I rename that as b1 and then I
rename b1 is BJ so now my set looks like
this let me go to the other color b2 and
you know for all we know BJ might have
been b1 we don't know and it doesn't I
mean there might have there's probably
multiple of these that are nonzero so we
could have picked any of those to be our
BJ but anyway we were so we removed we
took our BJ renamed it b1 and removed
the b1 and so now our set looks like
this
b3 all the way to BM and this will still
span this set still spans spans V and we
know that because the guy we removed can
be constructed with any linear
combination of these guys so we haven't
lost our ability to construct all of the
vectors in V now let me create another
vector let me create the vector B let me
do a new color
let's say I have the vector B 2 prime
and what I'm gonna do here is now I'm
going to take another element from our
spanning from our basis of V I'll take
the second element I'll take a - I'll
take a 2 and throw it on this guy so now
we have the set let me write it this way
B 2 is B 2 prime is equal to I'm just
going to add a 2 to this guy so you have
a 1 a 2 and then you have all the rest
of these guys B 2 B 3 all the way to BM
and of course this still spans V I just
added something here but this is
definitely linearly dependent remember I
didn't say in the beginning whether this
was linear dependent or not I just may
or may not be but when you add this
other vector that's in V you definitely
know that your linear dependent
because these guys can construct that
guy similarly we know that this vector
b1 this bands V so when we add this new
element here when we add this new
element here we know that it can be
written as a linear combination of the
other one so we know that this right
here is linearly dependent and we could
say that a 2 a 2 is equal to you know
some constant times c1 times a 1 plus
let me put some constants so plus d2
actually let me just write it this way
since plus C 2 B 2 plus C 3 B 3 all the
way to CM BM now what I'm going to claim
is that at least one of these
coefficients is nonzero so at least one
of the CIS does not equal to 0 and I'll
make the further claim that it's it's if
there's at least one that's outside of
this one there's at least one that's
outside of that one that it has to be
that at least one of the coefficients on
these bees on these B terms has to be
nonzero and the way you can kind of
think about it is what if all of these
guys were zero if all of these guys were
zero then that means that a 2 is a
linear combination of a 1 right all of
these guys would cancel out here to have
a 2 is equal to some nonzero constant
times a 1 but we know that's not the
case because these two guys come from
the same linear linearly independent set
they come they both come from that
spanning basis spanning beta the the
fact that they are a basis that would
the word spanning basis I shouldn't say
it like that because it's redundant a
basis is a spanning set that is linearly
independent if they're linearly
independent we know that a2 cannot be
represented as some linear combination
of the rest of these guys so we know
that one of these one of the
coefficients on the B terms has to be
nonzero and let's once again let's just
say that you know it's the coefficient
someplace you're gonna you're gonna have
a CJ BJ this is a different one than we
had before and we know that this guy one
of them at least one of them has to be
nonzero because if all of these guys
were nonzero then you wouldn't be able
to say that these get this vector and
that vector are linearly independent
because if they would be scalar
multiples of each other so we're gonna
do the same exercise
this guy right here that's some place
you know CJ beat CJ BJ right here
obviously this coefficient is nonzero so
we can solve for our BJ once again we
could say that BJ is equal to minus 1
over CJ times now it's minus a 2 plus C
1 a 1 all the way to CM BM so we have
some BJ here that is can be represented
as a linear combination of the rest of
the people including our new a2 and so
just like we did before let's remove him
let's take him out of the set and before
I take him out of the set I'm gonna
rename him just for the city just for
solely for the purpose of notational
simplicity I'm just gonna rename our BJ
B 2 and our B 2 is equal to BJ so I'm
just rearranging the names and I'm gonna
remove our b2 or I'm gonna remove what
what I now call our b2 it was that it
was it was whatever was out here that
could be represented as a linear
combination of everything else including
our new a2 so let me call that set when
I remove that that one of those terms
right here and now I renamed it be - I
call this set B - and now it's equal to
a-1 a-2 and now I have the leftovers of
my B's so I have b3 b4 all the way to BM
I used to notice I still have exactly M
elements and this still spans so this
spans V it spans V because the element
that I took out of it can be represented
as a linear combination of these guys so
if I ever want to construct anything
that needed that I can construct that
vector with some combination of these
guys so it wasn't necessary so it still
spans V so this process I'm doing I can
just keep repeating it I can add an a3 i
can define I can define b3 prime as I
can just add a 3 to this to this set
right here a 2 a 3 and then
have my B 3 B 4 all the way to BM and
I'll say oh this is linearly independent
this is linearly dependent because this
guy spans V so everything but this guy
spans V so obviously you can construct
this guy with a linear combination of
the rest of them so you could say a 3 is
equal to sum a 1 plus some a 2 plus C 3
B 3 all the way to CM BM and we know
that at least one of the coefficients on
the B terms on the B terms has to be
nonzero because if all of those were
zero then you would be saying that a
three could be a linear combination of
the a terms and we know that a three
can't be represented as a linear
combination of the eight terms because
it lays all these eight terms come from
a linearly independent set so you do the
same operation you find you can solve
you know let's say that CJ you know some
term right here the CJ is nonzero then
you can solve for that BJ and then you I
do that little renaming little thing I
do or I rename the BJ be three and
rename be three BJ and then I remove be
three and I get the set and I get the
set B 3 is equal to a1 a2 a3 and then I
have B 4 all the way to BM and this
still spans this still spans V and I
keep doing it so what's going to happen
eventually what's gonna happen if I keep
doing this process over and over and
over again eventually I'll I'll
essentially replace all of the BMS right
or I'll replace all of the N terms right
so eventually I'll have a set that looks
like this I'll have a set that looks BM
well I will replaced each of these guys
with an A where I would have replaced
each of these guys with an A so I'll
have a 1 a 2 a 3 all the way to a em you
can always do this by definition if you
started with that initial set B that is
a spanning set and once you do this
process you'll get the same result that
this also spans
viii now let me let me write this this
is the result we got by starting off
with a spanning set B by starting with a
spanning set B that has m elements where
we said that M is less than n right so
we always have enough a elements to do
this because we have more a elements
than there were B elements to begin with
and we get result that this bands V but
we already said we already said that the
set a the set a which is equal to a1 a2
all the way to a m and then a M plus you
know 1 I don't know how you know and
then we have I don't know how many more
terms there are between m and n but then
you go all the way to a n remember we
said that n is greater than M or when we
define B we said that M is less than and
same thing that this was a smaller set
now we're saying that this bands V but
at the same time we said that this was a
basis right this was just our this is
just our starting fact that this is a
basis for V basis for V basis means two
things it means it's bands V and it
means it's linearly independent now we
just got this result by assuming that we
had some set B that's smaller than this
set here that spans V we were able to
construct this by saying that a1 through
am also spans V so this the result we
got is that this fans V but if this if
this subset of a spans V then a becomes
linearly independent because of this sub
this subset spans V we can write that
means that a n can be represented as
some linear combination of these guys
which would imply so that implies that
you're linearly dependent which is a
contradiction with our original
statement that that set a is a basis for
V because that means it's linearly
independent if you're able to do this
then this means that this is if there
are some smaller spanning set you get
the result that a has to be linearly
dependent even though we said it was
linearly independent so we now know we
get our contradiction we say that there
cannot be there cannot be so this leads
us to there cannot be
let me there cannot be a set a let me
write this a spanning spanning set B
that has has fewer elements has fewer
elements than a and this is a pretty
neat outcome because now if anyone tells
you that you know if I come up to you
and I say hey I found some set X so set
X spans the subspace subspace I don't
know let's just call that V again then
you know that you know an X has X has
five elements you now know that no set
that spans the subspace V can have fewer
than five elements even better if I told
you that X is a basis X is a basis for V
and I told you that and it has five
elements and Y is a basis for V y is
another basis my handwriting is
degrading Y is let me write it a little
nicer Y is also a basis also a basis for
V you know that Y also has to have
exactly five elements Y has five
elements how do I know that how do I
know that well if Y is a basis then it
has to have then that means that it
spans V and we know it can't have
anything less than five elements we just
proved that so you know one way we know
that Y has to have greater than or equal
to five elements but on the other hand
we know if Y is a basis we know that Y
is a basis for V and X is a basis X also
spans V so we know that X has to have
fewer elements than Y so we know that Y
has to have greater than X or let me
call it wise elements wise elements have
to be greater than X's elements
because why any spanning set has to have
more elements or at least as many
elements as a basis set X's elements and
then since X is a spanning set X's
elements have to be greater than or
equal to wise elements because Y is a
basis Y is elements I know this is you
can you can't read that but if these if
this guy's elements are less than this
guy's elements and this and but it's
also greater than or equal to we know
that X the number of elements that X has
so X's elements or the cardinality or
the number of elements in it is equal to
Y's elements y's elements and so now
that we know that any basis for a vector
space so let's say let's say that X
though let me just go back to our set a
a is equal to a1 a2 all the way to a n
we can now say that any basis for some
vector force firms for some subspace V
they all have the same number of
elements and so we can we can define a
new term called the dimension the
dimension of V sometimes it's written
just dimension of V is equal to the
number of elements sometimes called the
cardinality of any basis of V and I went
through great Franzen's video show that
any basis of V all has the same number
of elements so this is well defined you
can't have one basis that has five
elements and one that has six by
definition they would either both have
to have 5 or they both have to have 6
and so we can define our dimensionality